new concerns about the omicron variants
a record level of children under the age
of five are being hospitalized amid a
climbing infection rate on friday the
supreme court heard arguments about the
bidet administration's employer
vaccination mandates all of this as the
average number of new daily cases topped
614 000 this week
michael george is here with the latest
michael good morning jeff good morning
experts note that omicron appears to be
less severe than other variants but the
sheer fact that it's spreading so fast
and so many people are getting sick is
putting a strain on employers and on
hospitals where more and more children
are being hospitalized
in the midst of an omicron emergency it
is so easy to transmit that there are
lots of patients that have it but thanks
to the vaccine they are experiencing
either no no symptoms or very mild
symptoms but unvaccinated individuals
who test positive are 17 times more
likely to be hospitalized according to
the cdc
and this is the view from st louis where
denise huffman is an icu nurse we're
seeing younger people die we're seeing
people dying
who are leaving behind young children
and teenagers
in florida the cleveland clinic's
hospitals on the treasure coast shifted
to level red overwhelmed by patients
nationally covet hospitalizations are up
in 46 states a 40 rise from the previous
week's average the rate of
hospitalization for children under five
who are not yet eligible for vaccines is
the highest since the pandemic began
doubling since last month the storm's
going to pass i mean that's the the
great news and what we're seeing out of
other countries is that it's a fast big
peak but then we've also seen it seen it
also start to decline fairly rapidly
compared to some of the other streams
the president friday also offered some
hope covid
as we're dealing with it now
is not here to state we're going to be
able to control this the new normal is
not going to be what it is now it's
going to be better the president's
requirement that some 80 million
employees at large companies either be
vaccinated or get tested weekly faced a
challenge in the supreme court friday
missouri's deputy attorney general
argued for an injunction to stop it
without the injunction rural america
will face an imminent crisis tell me
what's irrational about rules of that
nature when it is the workplace that
puts you into contact with people that
will put you at risk
citibank wasn't waiting for a court
ruling at the end of the month its
unvaccinated employees will be fired
and some good news from south africa
where the omicron variant was first
identified their covet surge is
declining as fast as it began according
to new studies now the cdc says there's
a good chance that could happen here as
well but they caution that different
parts of the country will likely surge
at different times michelle
michael thank you